- Welcome back, y'all.
It's Sports Ball Day here at the show.
We've got an audience full of NFL fans,
including my friends up
in Wayfair VIP Lounge.
And of course we're joined by
the stars of the new movie 80 for Brady,
Jane Fonda, Lily Tomlin,
Sally Field, Rita Moreno.
So you've all managed
to survive these years
in a tough business for women.
We talked about that a little earlier,
but I heard this crazy thing
that I actually really hope isn't true,
but I heard a director once gave you
the worst excuse ever when
he tried to sleep with you.
Is this right?
Is what I heard right? Is it true?
- I think so. Yeah. He was a French,
not the French director
I ended up marrying,
but he was a French director
and he came over here to try to cast me
in a film he was doing with Yves Montand.
They don't know.
There'd be moans if you knew
who I was talking about.
Yeah.
I didn't speak French very well then.
And he spoke no English,
but I knew that he was telling me
that we needed to sleep together
because the character in
the movie had an orgasm
and he needed to see how I orgasmed.
And boy, did I not know
French at that moment.
It was like, "What? I don't."
- What did you, what?
- I did the movie.
- But what did you do?
- I did not sleep with him, though.
- Yeah. No, no. But I.
That's appalling to me.
Like I just can't, I.
Have y'all ever had anything like that
happen in a movie?
Oh my gosh.
- Yep.
- Yeah. There's worse.
Believe me.
- Sure.
- Much worse.
He just went to jail.
- Oh, yep, yep, yep, yep.
(audience applauding)
- Years ago when I was,
I wanted Gidget's part
and I wanted Sybil's part.
Didn't get either one.
- You didn't want the flying nun?
- I wanted everything.
And so I went up to see a producer
and he said to me, he was all rust.
His hair was rust, his suit was rust,
his complexion was rust.
He was very tanned and he was writing
and he said, "Well, you know,
if you don't get this part,
you can always come
and keep house for me."
But a very suggestive
- Sexual way.
- What an amazing offer, thank you.
- And I said, "What?"
- I would've said, "Hard pass."
- I wasn't that hip.
I said, "Oh, I don't think so."
- Oh my God.
- I was invited when I
was 19 to a cocktail party
of a very famous guy who
ran a whiskey industry
and we went up to dance
and he was starting to grind against me.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, there's no other way to put it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he said to me, coming outta nowhere,
we're dancing and he's
pressing really hard.
And he says, "You're a sexy
little bitch, aren't you?"
And I said, "Excuse me."
He said, "Don't give me that (beep)."
He said, "I bet you are
really wild in bed."
- Oh my gosh.
- I'd never, I didn't even know his name.
- He's probably right.
- Wait.
- What did you say?
- [Kelly] Probably right.
But girlfriends can say that.
- I pushed him away and
went into the bathroom
and the mascara is running and I'm crying
and I didn't know what to do
and I decided to just leave and walk home.
And home was miles away.
And I didn't have, I had
$1 in my little purse
and the lipstick and the Mexican guys
who were doing the gardens there,
'cause this was a daytime cocktail party.
- Yeah.
- Said to me, "Can we help you?"
They just knew.
And I said, "I really have to go home.
I just have to go home, can you help me?"
And they took me home to Culver City
in our little cottage
where my mom and I lived
and dropped me off.
And those were the first
gentlemen I had met that day.
- Wow.
(audience applauding)
What can I say?
I'm sorry you had to go through it.
That's a lot of (beep).
Besides acting, you're all
known for social activism.
Is that sense of responsibility
something that you've always had
or do you feel like you have that,
because you're in the spotlight,
you have the opportunity?
- For me, it was learning
about the Vietnam War
and when I really understood
what that was about,
I couldn't not do anything,
except try to join the
movement to stop it.
- And that was where I started.
'Cause you were pretty
active even after that.
- Yeah, well, you can take anything.
Sexism, racism, misogyny,
homophobia, whatever, the war.
And if you really get into it
and study it and learn about it
and the history of it and
everything's connected.
There'd be no climate crisis
if it wasn't for racism.
- How do you get to that, tell me.
- Where would they put the (beep)?
Where would they put the
poison and the pollution?
They're not gonna put it in Bel Air.
They've gotta find some
place where poor people
or indigenous people or
people of color are living.
Put it there. They can't fight back.
And that's why a big part
of the climate movement
now has to do with climate justice.
The first
(audience applauding)
- It's actually, we just actually covered,
it's called The Descendant and it's
- Oh yeah.
- And Questlove was on here and we had
people from the the documentary on here
and that's part of the
problem with Africa Town.
They're getting pushed out
because they don't have the opportunity
for the education to
get out, to fight back.
And they're just
encroaching upon their land.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That they've had since they were.
Their ancestors are descendants
to people that were kidnapped.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's absolutely true.
And I'm glad you actually
asked her to explain that
because that's important.
I don't think people
see that, the parallel,
or how it's all connected, but 100% true.
- Is it, Rita, is this true?
I didn't know this, but you
were at the march on Washington
where Dr. King gave his
I Have a Dream speech.
What was that experience like?
- Oh.
- That's incredible.
- I really can't even talk about it
without immediately getting goosebumps.
I was there, Harry Belafonte,
who was a big star then,
a black wonderful singer,
decided to put a whole Hollywood.
There I am with Sammy Davis Jr.
and I'm only making a face
'cause it was boiling, boiling hot.
Anyway, Dr. King was about,
I'll make this shorter,
was about to speak.
And he started his speech and next to him
was sitting his dear best
friend, Mahalia Jackson,
who was a wonderful gospel singer.
And he started a speech
that she wasn't expecting.
I seem to be the only
one who saw this happen.
And she tugs on his jacket and she says,
"Martin, tell them about the dream.
Tell them about the dream, Martin."
And he changed his speech.
I just can barely say this without crying.
And he started to say, "I had a dream."
And I mean
- Wow.
- I was there.
I saw this, I saw this happen.
- You felt it.
- Saw thousands,
thousands of people at the pool
and back with the monument.
I saw all this and I was there.
And I'll never forget
it as long as I live.
(audience applauding)
- It's a powerful, powerful
thing to be a part of.
This is completely switching it,
but I also heard you had
some really useful
advice from Dolly Parton.
Can you share that?
Because this is
- Can I actually?
- Dolly Parton, I love it.
- So when I was doing Violet's part
in the TV series of Nine to Five,
Dolly came in to do the
song all over again.
She wanted to do a recording
just of her voice singing that,
not for the movie, but for our series.
So I said, "Can I?
I wanna ask you something
a little personal, may I?"
"Sure."
And I said, "okay, have
you ever had the experience
of getting on stage about
to maybe sing a song
and you get a big gas
bubble in your belly?"
- That is not great.
- So I said, "What do you do?"
And she laughed and she
giggled and she said,
"What do you do?"
And I said, "Well, I wait
for the trumpets to play."
- Oh, I thought
I thought that the story was she said,
"I wait for the trumpets."
That was you said, "I
wait for the trumpets."
That just got better.
- Oh, she loved it.
She laughed so hard.
But it's true.
That's what I would do.
I'd wait.
- Oh my God.
- And then they'd be going
(imitates trumpet sound)
(imitates fart sound)
- Everyone that's ever seen
you in concert right now
is like, "I wonder if she was ripping then
while I was watching her?"